digamos que tengo la integral indefinida
de uno que está dividido sobre la raíz
cuadrada de tres menos dos equis
cuadrada aquí va de xy cuando lo observo
no tengo una anti derivada a la mano
para hacer una sustitución o como
normalmente lo haríamos pero lo que sí
puedo hacer es decir esto casi se parece
a una de las identidades trigonométricas
que conozco buscar alguna y sustituirlo
por esta así que vamos a sustituirla por
alguna identidad trigonométricas que se
parezca a esto que tenemos aquí de las
identidades trigonométricas básicas y de
la definición del círculo unitario
sabemos qué seno cuadrado de teta más
coseno cuadrado de teta es igual a 1 si
restamos coseno cuadrado de teta de
ambos lados bueno también podríamos
restar el seno cuadrado de teta
obtenemos coseno cuadrado de teta es
igual a uno menos el seno cuadrado
de teta podemos observar que esto que
tenemos aquí se empieza a parecer a esto
que tenemos aquí tendré que hacer un
poco de manipulación algebraica para
hacer que esto se parezca más a lo que
tengo acá y lo primero que necesito es
un 1 así que puedo empezar factor izando
el 3 entonces esto es igual a la
integral de 1 sobre la raíz ahora voy a
factorizar el 3 que sea de tres veces
que multiplica a uno menos dos tercios
de x cuadrada y la verdad no hice nada
complicado para llegar a esto y lo único
que hice fue factorizar el 3 y veamos
ahora esta expresión se parece mucho a
esta otra expresión pero lo importante
aquí es que si yo logro que dos tercios
de x cuadrada se parezca a seno cuadrado
de theta podría sustituir con esta
identidad así que vamos a hacerlo sea
dos tercios de x cuadrada
igual hacen o cuadrado de tetas
ahora vamos a tomar la raíz cuadrada en
ambos lados
esto será entonces la raíz de 2 entre la
raíz de 3x es igual al seno de teta
ahora vamos a resolver para x y bueno
también vamos a querer resolver para
theta tenemos que hacer los dos así que
empecemos con teta y entonces theta
sería igual al arco seno de raíz de dos
sobre raíz de 3x
vamos a resolver para x por lo que
tomamos el inverso de este y vamos a
escribir x igual a raíz de 3
sobre raíz de 2
por el seno de teta y ahora vamos a
sustituir esto por el seno cuadrado de
teta y no podemos dejar así nada más la
equis porque lo vamos a integrar con
respecto a de teta entonces ahora veamos
quién es de equis y de equis con
respecto a beteta iba a ser la raíz de 3
sobre la raíz de 2 por la derivada de
seno de teta que es coseno de teta ahora
vamos a escribirlo esto en términos de
de x y entonces de x será a la raíz de 3
sobre la raíz de 2 por el coseno de teta
beteta y ahora sí podemos sustituirlo
aquí arriba y vamos a reescribir lo
entonces saber en esta área voy a
escribir
vamos a utilizar un color azul y
reescribir esto nos quedará la integral
de 1 x de x pero puedo escribirlo
directamente en el numerador así de x
aquí arriba y que es de x
bueno pues de x es lo que tenemos aquí
escrito en amarillo
qué dice la raíz de 3 sobre la raíz de
dos coseno de teta de teta y eso es lo
que es de equis y ahora que tenemos en
el denominador bueno en el denominador
tenemos que es la raíz cuadrada de tres
veces uno menos y sustituyó dos tercios
de x cuadrada por seno cuadrado de teta
y ahora vamos a simplificar uno menos
seno cuadrado de teta y resulta que uno
menos seno cuadrado de teta es el coseno
cuadrado de teta si lo que está aquí es
coseno cuadrado de teta y entonces voy a
escribir ahora mi integral indefinida
como la raíz de tres sobre la raíz de
dos por el coseno de teta beteta y todo
esto sobre la raíz de tres veces el
coseno cuadrado de teta
y ahora resolvamos la raíz cuadrada que
está aquí abajo así que voy a cambiar de
colores de una manera arbitraria a
cualquier color y esto va a ser entonces
la integral de raíz de tres sobre raíz
de dos coseno de teta de teta
todo eso / raíz de 3
por el coseno de teta esto simplifica
mucho las cosas porque este coseno de
teta cancela a este otro coseno de teta
y esta raíz de 3 cancela a la otra raíz
de 3 por lo que ahora puedo re escribir
esto como la integral de uno sobre raíz
de dos x de teta podemos continuar y
debido a que este número es una
constante lo puedo sacar de la integral
y escribirlo como 1 sobre la raíz de 2
la integral de de teta y esta es
sencillísima porque se resuelve en 1
sobre raíz de dos tetas
más si se es una constante podríamos
hacer algunas reflexiones acerca de ella
pero dejémoslo que es una constante
arbitraria y yo creo que tú puedes
trabajar con esto y ya terminamos pero
no la verdad no porque no está integral
original está en términos de equis y
aquí tenemos en términos de theta de lo
anterior
sabemos que teta es el arco seno de raíz
de 2 / raíz de 3x así que mi integral
indefinida la que está aquí arriba todo
esto que tenía yo aquí arriba lo voy a
poder ahora sustituir como 1 sobre la
raíz de dos tetas pero theta es esto que
está aquí arriba que es simplemente es
el arco seno de la raíz de 2 sobre la
raíz de 3
y tengo esta constante o sea más la
constante así que todo esto que tengo
aquí todo esto que está aquí es la anti
derivada de 1 sobre la raíz de 3 menos 2
x al cuadrado voy a hacer más ejemplos
en próximos vídeos